cinquante ans déjà le début avec un
legging de la guadeloupe
ensuite exhale juan cadence lypso et le
reste c'est l'histoire
50 ans c'est qu'en terme de carrière
donc ça a commencé la tournée mondiale
ça a tous commencé par la réunion pas la
réunion et on doit terminer à la ligne
[Musique]
on a déjà fait bien sûr donc l'océan
indien
on doit brûler là bas pour les échelles
on a déjà fait la dominique
chez nous un petit clin d'oeil à la
guadeloupe
je suis un martinique là maintenant pour
préparer notre concert en fin d'année de
la martinique
mais on va faire deux petites
prestations intimes le 20 et le 21
juillet en martinique après on continue
à new york donc dans le cadre de la
tournée à bolquère music festival
on doit passer en octobre et ça continue
[Musique]
la cadence lypso les d'actualité
aujourd'hui
oui bizarrement parce que on sait bien
que ça c'est une musique des années 70
mais poindre raison ça dure les gens ont
envie d'écouter et avec grand plaisir la
grana si vous êtes à jour
[Musique]
tous les pays lusophones homme ça fait
des années un homme depuis les années 70
sont adeptes
si on regarde sur youtube on va trouver
plusieurs versions et ils copiaient
hexagone la façon qu'ont fait les
pochettes la face on s'habillait avec
nos impôts est tout jeune et plus à flot
maintenant heureusement hockey
malheureusement et elle ça continue mais
le zouk aa fait la suite à de sapir de
carrasso dans les pays les voir
[Musique]